hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba hi I'm
John Humphrey and I am åkesson Akasaka
song is here today read dreaded nation I
put out a tweet or a Facebook post or
maybe both and saying what should I
check out with aqus on the reactor this
got sent yeah so Howard boy with cancer
asked comedians to attend his funeral
but he has one special request thank you
for that I know nothing's gonna be funny
I mean the boys in this thumbnail this
penis this is gonna be very sore cry or
maybe get ready try not let's all sit up
straight yes it's okay to cry out we get
those tears in HD that's the only way I
sleep men men can cry only during
sometimes Terminator 2 only as a funny
answer so their son was battling with
cancer would I come to see him was he of
course so went to see he was really
funny properly funny
he had an iPad of my favorite jokes on
his iPad and he was doing like that's
very good very good very good [ __ ] was
his favorite chocolate mine was a sketch
cousin mr. dildo
now I'd forgotten that seminal piece of
arms babe's escapes they involved me
dressed in a 6-foot cop costume chasing
after old ladies it isn't the high art
but it's funny with cancer laughs but I
tell you this now there isn't a lovely
sight in the world he was just sad like
abrir your dress is a [ __ ] you're
chasing an old
[Laughter]
you sort of adapt and you become funny
he was doing a bucket list I went to see
him a few times he wanted to meet Simon
Pegg he wanted to drive a fast car by
all accounts that was quite experienced
[Music]
and he wanted to meet me
but the fifth time no I went to see him
he said to me will you come to my
funeral no no is something that you can
never okay so for you don't know I'm
quite got beat one thing I've pretty bad
but in that moment I did know what to
say I was like look to me really steely
gaze and just win don't be a dick it's
gonna be amazing but it gets even better
he's designing the costumes that people
have to wear at his funeral
he's making his dad go to his funeral
dressed as the Grim Reaper
if anyone coughs his bad side pointed
them
sorry guys camera cut and we back I
couldn't believe how brave he was he was
fighting fear with funny I was in all of
him it's a good idea to miss very funny
what do you want me to wear anyway you
know he wants me to wear a throbbing
six-foot [ __ ] costume to a
fourteen-year-old boys fear in case
you're struggling to visualize that this
is the outfit he's deemed appropriate
for me to wear that's
oh boy that's pretty graphic come on
will I've already planned the route I've
planned the route therefore it's every
single school on the way I am not this
young in the eyes a nice best I could
and I said I will do this but you need
to write me a letter saying that this
was your idea because 95% of me believes
you but there is five percent as I look
deep into her eyes Carrie's swimming
rejoining people what if that is the
ultimate prank what if I arrive the few
everyone's dressed in black the door
creaks
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the best thing about him with every
great story became to twist and this was
it I saw him just after Christmas he'd
been given three days to live he planned
his own funeral and then he got tested
and he no longer had cancer his blood
counts had gone up he was no longer
dying how [ __ ] amazing really [ __ ]
right it's amazing
can I tell you so yeah I want in fact at
the end of the recording of the DVD
you're gonna come on stage
sure yes you are [ __ ] right what do
you want me to wear
[Applause]
a man life goals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
I've never heard this comedian I've
heard his name
really I've never heard a rustle how're
that man is a damn good storyteller you
know he's a wonderful storyteller I love
a convenient could tell a damn good
story and what a story very well was I
loved that message that he had fighting
fear with fear with funny funny funny
fear with funny I'm never gonna forget
that that'd be cool tattoo funny yeah
yeah that'd be awesome
I feel like I fight everything when
funny you know like intimacy connections
that should be taken serious fear I
totally give it would you have a funeral
like that did you want to make it funny
I I don't I would like to I wonder if
it's like it depends if I if I died
before my mom died you probably tell me
yes and then tell everyone know why mom
but I could see myself having a fun
funeral no unfortunately men sit quite a
few and I feel like at funerals
sometimes the best moments are the
eulogies there's often times people have
like really funny stories throughout
right if it's like the person who died
their specific request I would like that
if you like instead of like I want
everyone to be really sad for me I just
want her owner I think it'd be cool if
it I don't remember like how fun it was
you know to keep living on good as funny
having our side I think that is cool it
for like a little boy to be having it's
a 14 year old with a boy with like dirty
joke mind you know that's fine yeah yeah
if you had the opportunity of that age
to hop into a dick you it's probably we
would find that 40 bits even funnier at
14 yeah
that's probably when it's funniest story
yeah you run up so I'm sure you've
gotten some of this before when if
someone feels very inspired by a
comedian you know like I I don't think
what I do on YouTube is something that
is like the most monumental thing the
planet but every once in a while I meet
someone and just the other day someone
was telling me like I went through their
mother passing and then when I found
your channel it really helped me out
because you're so funny then it really
helped keep me going and keep my spirits
up lifted it's crazy when someone tells
you something like that this little boys
is how do you like that it's just an
awesome experience with a hero of his
yes the kind of hero you want to be due
to rejects ever get letters like that
from twelve-year-old thirteen-year-old
kids absolutely a few years ago the
second year of our channel there was I
think his name was Tanner ten year old
boy who was dying of cancer and his
sister hit us up so we did like a shout
out compilation of a bunch of different
people have been on the channel to give
a shout out for him he did pass away
eventually so that's like that's a
closest experience I've ever had to
share the love share the love firing
fightings ear with funny I want to have
a cookie funeral I don't see how I want
my funeral to be like a little bit funny
but also you know just enough to be
heartfelt like I don't want everyone to
be somber I do want there to be
surprises I would want when people goes
visit my body that they have to youtube
channel to make it sound like you're
actually speaking to me hi how are you
and I also want this to carry over into
my tombstone is I would like to be when
they you know taxidermy you at the end
you know and get make y'all nice I would
like to be in the coffin with my hand up
so that people can give me like one last
hand
I just want my hand to be sticking out
in a way that says like come shake me
yeah I would just like to spring my
funeral Wow oh you definitely the other
thing and then I wouldn't have that hand
taken and I would have it transplanted
onto the side of my tombstone so that
you can
take it and when you do it says one of
my fun phrases oh yeah okay you mean
like six days days like that [ __ ] 2016
all right well I guess we're looking
forward to dying we've thought about it
if you like to donate we hit up our
patreon for our funeral primarily Ochs
everyone is dressed phallic ly then it's
not weird new subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification Bell -
on Twitter and Instagram and patreon.com
slash the real rejects become a patron
eject today acha son is on YouTube he
has reactions reviews sketches he is a
little more editing than us just a
little bit is a tad bit more every once
while you do like effects bastard CGI
yeah it just takes that much longer for
that much little work no one cares about
oh damn it's they just want to see the
reaction not listen to the discussion
but in the retainer on the video is haha
the news on this video right now just
skip what we're saying right yeah no
they saw the video these are people who
are letting us play in the background